fatal drug overdoses spiking to
record levels in the u.s last year as
illegal narcotics continue to flow into
the country from the southern border
and the pictures here the disturbing
images you see on your screen
are drugs tons of drugs
seized by border patrol agents in just
the last month alone
former dea agent derek waltz joins me
now
we see those images and it really is is
a crisis
i mean there is no question about it
even though the administration once
actually hesitated to call it a crisis
how have border policies under the biden
administration
fueled this drug crisis in our country
well first of all i want to thank the
brave men and women of the border patrol
and cbp
for their relentless effort to keep the
drugs out of the country and save
lives so the policies obviously are
hurting our national security
uh the crime is escalating around the
country but most importantly julie
is the mexican cartels are now the enemy
of our children
they are engaged in a sustained deadly
assault
against our americans future generation
of kids
so you look at the fentanyl poisoning
you look at the fentanyl murders that's
what it is this is no longer
just an opioid addiction or opioid
crisis
because the kids they may stay away from
pills or stay away
from opioids and go to cocaine or
methamphetamine
but they're dying instantly this is
murder so we have to change the
perception
we have to change the education and our
schools our teachers our parents
have to know that this is a deadly
crisis we've never seen this in the
history of the country
for our viewers to understand the
seriousness behind fentanyl okay
it is between 50 and 100 times stronger
than morphine
that's an opa which is used in hospitals
to treat serious pain
a lot of times used to treat patients
who are at the end of their lives
okay fentanyl seizures are skyrocketing
at the border over the last three years
alone fentanyl seizures are
up 4 000 percent here on this program
yesterday payne founder virginia krieger
had this to say about the border opening
her daughter
died because of this kind of drug use
and how the the border crisis is opening
the door
to illegal drugs watch this
partnership in combination with our
current border policies
have allowed this fentanyl to
continuously pour over the southwest
border
practically unabated i think it's
interesting in this interview she talked
about the fact that
you know the people that are dying are
not necessarily your typical drug users
those who are addicted her daughter was
not addicted to this drug it was a
one-time thing
she said that that kids should learn
from their mistakes not
die from them i mean which is an
excellent point
so anyway julie look this is a beautiful
young girl
she was coming home for a christmas
break from arizona state university
right alex capilouto from california
and the parents found it dead from one
oxycontin pill that was purchased
on social media this is different this
is not like anything this country has
ever faced and it's really aggravating
that the mainstream media will continue
to call it an opioid crisis
kids are taking drugs let's let's not
worry about it the parents aren't
parenting
no this is the mexican cartels who have
formed a deadly partnership with the
chinese criminals
to really destroy our future that's what
it is we have to stop dancing around the
issue
look at the cdc stats 93 000 people died
last year
those numbers are way under reported as
well and the majority of fentanyl
related
the coroner report in ohio first six
months of 2020 reflects 85 percent of
the deaths
are related to fentanyl so it's fentanyl
coming from labs in mexico
across our border flooding our streets
all over america
that's what we're dealing with this is
different this is not kids
you know going into the medicine cabinet
of their parents this is different so we
have to change what we're saying
yeah and we got to make some change at
the border uh derrick maltz thank you
very much for talking to us this morning